In Japan, Prime Minister Shinzo Abe...
...said he will declare a state of emergency for Tokyo and six other prefectures as early as Tuesday...
...in the fight against the coronavirus outbreak, but that there will be no hard lockdowns.
In Britain, Prime Minister Boris Johnson, who last week tested positive for the coronavirus,...
...remained hospitalized Monday for additional testing after having a persistent high fever.
In Germany, the government has drawn up a list of steps...
...to help enable a phased return to normal life after its coronavirus lockdown ends on April 19.
In the Ivory Coast, police in Abidjan fired tear gas at protesters...
...after youths set up burning barricades and tried to dismantle a mobile testing center for the coronavirus.
Finally from the US, a tiger at the Bronx Zoo has tested positive for the new coronavirus,...
...in what is believed to be the first known infection in an animal in the United States or a tiger anywhere.